The global health crisis has caused unemployment to soar...
...and has turned the working world on its head,...
...but some say the solution to the crisis lies not in working more but in working less.
Working four days but getting paid for five sounds too good to be true,...
...and there's a fair share of skeptics.
The Confederation of British Industry cautions that it could push many businesses into loss,...
...but proponents claim fewer hours doesn't harm productivity.
There are three main ways which we can see that decreasing hours...
...is good for productivity and good for the economy.
We can look at our own history to see that when we move from a six to a five-day working week,...
...it was accompanied by an increase in productivity...
...and it was good for the economy overall.
You can also look at other countries and take a map for our analysis...
...and we can see that countries that worked fewer hours...
...tend to have much stronger economies...
...and tend to be much more productive than countries that work lots of hours.
And finally, we can see real and existing examples of...
...firms and organizations who are experimenting with reductions in working hours.
They are doing this and seeing the increases...
...in terms of increased well-being, decreased sick leave, decreased turnover...
...and it's clearly good for these organizations that they have reduced working time.